they are trying to basically drug
everybody constantly right we know this
we know this and that brought us to this
video we've been trying to figure out a
way to get this into the show for a
little while now you may remember this
this is from how long is this ago this
is about 10 years ago right this is
about a decade ago listen to Tom Cruise
yeah Tom Cruise that Tom Cruise talking
about the coercive use of uh 80 ADHD
drugs Sr SSRI drugs and how they are
pushing that stuff on children this is
10 years ago take a look
here we are today where I talk out
against drugs
and psychiatric abuses of electric
shocking people okay against their will
of drugging children with them not
knowing the effects of these drugs do
you know what Adderall is do you know
Ritalin do you know now that Ritalin is
a street drug
do you understand that the difference is
a question Matt I'm asking a question I
understand there's abuse of all of these
things now you see here's the problem
you don't know the history of Psychiatry
I do all it does is mask the problem
Matt and if you understand the history
of it it masks the problem
that's what it does
that's all it does
you're not getting to the reason why
there is no such thing as a chemical
imbalance I'm saying that drugs aren't
the answer that these these drugs are
very dangerous they're mind-altering
antipsychotic drugs and there are ways
of doing it without that so that we
don't end up in A Brave New World
okay I'm not testifying to every single
thing that Tom Cruise said there like is
there no such thing as a chemical
imbalance like I'm not sure about that
but I thought it was interesting because
uh that clip almost got him canceled 10
years ago
because there's a giant machine a giant
big Pharma machine that wants you
injected with things oh your kid's kind
of Jumpy we better put him on drugs oh
your kids climbing around a lot you
better put them on drugs I can tell you
having these two kids downstairs what I
have learned if I've learned anything in
the last nine months of having these two
boys Justin is a higher wire act this
kid he is an Explorer he wants to climb
and crawl into every crazy position if I
leave the back door open for a split
second he wants to bolt out of the house
he climbs on everything he's knocking
himself over trying to get upstairs like
it is built into this kid to go out
there and conquer the world and I'm
going to do everything that I can to
give him all the tools so that he can go
about his life and do that Justin's more
he just kind of Luke is more he just
kind of sits there and stares at you
he's more of a thinker but they're wired
a certain way but we have decided that
we will draw you're a boy but you think
you're a girl will drug you will
chemically castrate you oh you're
actually uh this kid's a little too
energetic we'll drug him this kid
doesn't have enough energy we'll drug
him we we are
screwing around with the chemicals in
our brain and then we wonder why we now
have a generation of people that don't
know what their what gender they are
[Music]
thank you